I think that we are giving a great  amount of thought to giving a lot of  consideration just a couple of weeks ago  I commissioned sage to set up a sub  group to look at the particular issues  of opening schools making ensure that  when schools are open it's done in the  best possible way with the very best  scientific and medical advice and we  expect a sage to reporting back and the  information that we get from sage along  with public health England will be the  key parts of what informs as to how best  we open schools but I do expect schools  to be opened in a phased manner I also  intend to be giving the schools as much  notice as as possible